yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing my way I'm not exactly sure what
he does against me for c400 if it the
Buddhist path scampered then I wasn't
really aware so I don't have played
deform against in every game that's a
good question ok so here white is
slightly better pleased because of the
space that he has ha looks like his out
55a for the move you are reluctant to
play really because of 85 84 85
94 there is 96 that doesn't help
and a little bit concerned here about b5
the whole setup here with c6 and and
them and a six is a bit unusual I wonder
actually what about this not yet 6 i'm
taking this in play Bishop e3 this makes
sense we should be three is the idea of
this whole thing also after Queen to c7
just trying to find a drawback of his
setup yeah there must be one I mean like
should not get away with this kind of
thing I mean at least white should have
a slight advantage so you trying to say
you shouldn't just equalize gem how does
he do this now Bishop to e7 defending
passively I probably will play Queen d2
look the one doubling on the d6 bomb and
c5 c5 looks wrong I mean that weakens a
lot might not be terrible okay so 22
rookie one was the thing let's do it
that looks
kind of normal yeah I now be five there
might work actually little bit it might
work maybe this is an idea toying with
the idea of Bishop 85 and if he plays a
five and sales d 5 is not going to
happen any time soon and I get to see
three okay so
yeah it's a good square therefore the
bishop let's think about this now how do
I play here there are a couple of things
I can play b4 b5 that will be a
strategic way of doing it and this is
working why I can take take take take on
b5 yeah I can take on me from Bishop b5
cb5 ship takes me five g's five bucks e7
looked to rookie to he takes at form
movie seven so why is that not working
then it is looking okay at least there
is no big drawback so Bishop to b4 or do
I have something better it's got some I
can go to beach so that you cannot take
it look a oneness the thing so yep so we
cannot take it and now my idea is to
play like a 3d 495 this is a good good
move to play yeah it's just a big big
pond down
yeah that looks good the big behind on
the clock Luke c7 blunders this I don't
want to blunder point but Luke c7 is
useful in the nearest future also funny
would be like Quincy 39 m 60 he cannot
take this but not a big problem not sure
that i played this that this sequence
was so great that's what I'm trying to
say but I still should have the
advantage 97 what is he doing there
taking on d3
we should be one um what happens there
should be one i was thinking i can take
on g7 here desperado in this time
morning and it's infected a queen trade
i don't want to trade Queens don't want
to do that all that much but I want to
pawn back to be perfectly honest yeah
you should trade now keeping queens on
this is pretty pretty awful and anything
is also pretty bad I get the rope to be
six and then it was on the corn nobody
have to basically create to that doesn't
work let me
skin position if is the word ZM let's
see probably this kh5 be 45 on the
seventh this is the way to do it I think
I cannot take unfortunately King f5 hmm
man it isn't that clear check check
check check check check check check draw
offered check check check check check
check check check me that can't happen
if you play on the time to really can
happen yeah yeah she'll just won the
game position wise and not like that it
was pretty bad yeah i was always
submitting this any i thought that this
was pretty easy win but it isn't huh I
probably miss it Josh dad
yeah I pride to go king at five now and
that was more that was more important
King at five f4 might still be a draw
what is this this I can actually do this
son a question that it's probably
examine then I shouldn't take on this
exam that's the thing one avoid the
capture it I mean this is not bad yeah
yeah yeah I can actually do this and
take with the book here this is great
yep this is a great position upon up and
he has no form structure yeah something
something like that I should do ok so
the Budapest I wonder if I found a good
solution there yeah night a choice and
94 is the the engine move it took a long
time but I think it was a good solution
pressurizing is Pawn can't yeah I got I
got some good play 24 but 22 is also
pretty ok you know so I was keeping a
comfortable advantage aha ye for was
even better hi for typical overloading
motifs as the bishop has to cover the
rook and she it has no square so I'm
winning a four-piece ah ok so this was
not as good and I mean this is awful a
problem may you see a really good
continuation like this one and you don't
even look at
further that bad ideas I had anticipated
but not the other one but okayed it
leads to a very clear edge here as well
so it was such a big difference i would
have liked to see it afore again the
ending is unfortunately a draw i guess i
don't think i can improve on this all
that much this this pawn structure is
the best that you can get down against
this right to draw it's at all you can
always sell give up the bpong for one of
the four pawn team ok guys thanks for
watching